comment des hommes en vient-il à l'idée
de tuer le chef de l'état des hommes
comme cela l'historien on rencontre tout
au long de l'histoire c'est jacques
clément qui tue henri iii c'est
ravaillac qui tue henri iv c caserio qui
tue sadi carnot
c'est d'orgueil l'oeuf qui tue paul
doumer et ces gens là on les appelle des
régicides mais l'historien constate chez
tous ces hommes
une caractéristique commune ce sont des
déséquilibrés ils ont eu des
hallucinations ce ne sont pas des gens
normaux
ce n'est pas le cas du colonel bastien
thiry ce n'est pas le cas des hommes qui
accompagne bastien thiry optique lama
pour tuer de gaulle alors pourquoi ces
hommes-là ont-ils voulu tuer de gaulle
le film que vous allez voir tentera de
répondre à cette question
c'est le temps où le conseil national de
la résistance
issu de l'ohada est ce le cnr de georges
bidault de jacques soustelle du colonel
argoud a condamné legault la mort
pourquoi et bien pour deux raisons fort
différentes la première parce qu'on
l'accuse d'avoir délibérément brad et
l'algérie alors ça c'est l'opération
vengeance c'est une opération temps
conséquent tout à fait stérile deuxième
raison parce que pense-t-on si de gaulle
meurt nous pourrons garder l'algérie or
les accords d'evian sont signés
l'algérie est perdu on ne voit pas du
tout le sens politique de cette seconde
raison alors pourquoi ces hommes ont-ils
voulu tuer de gaulle trois explications
encore avant que nous voyons ensemble le
film
d'abord on va parler d'enlèvement
c'est maître richard dupuis l'avocat de
bastien thiry qui suivant la thèse
exposée par son client procès dira qu'il
a voulu enlever de gaulle pour qu'ils
soient jugés ultérieurement par un
tribunal claude est en fête
nous ne parlons pas nous d'enlèvement
parce que nous les croyons pas j'ai
interrogé la plus haute autorité du cnr
et je suis autorisé à dire que jamais le
cnr n'a donné l'ordre d'enlever de boer
en fait ce qu'on a voulu faire au
petit-clamart s'est tué de gaulle alors
ne parlons plus d'enlèvements alors
également une autre explication nous
aurions voulu avoir devant la caméra
plusieurs des conjurés du petit-clamart
nous en avons 1 1 seulement
les autres n'ont pas voulu paraître nous
le regrettons mais c'était leur droit de
ne pas paraître
enfin notre constitution tente surtout
de suggérer ce qui s'est passé les
images tentent de suggérer et non pas de
montrer dans le détail ce qui s'est
passé par exemple la sphère du
petit-clamart s'est passé au mois d'août
et les images de paris et du
petit-clamart que vous verrez tout à
l'heure ont été tournées le mois dernier
alors que paris disparaît c'est sous la
neige
vous jugerez comme moi que c'est de très
peu d'importance
l'important c'est de savoir pourquoi on
a voulu tuer de gaulle au petit clamart
[Applaudissements]
22 août 1962 19h47 dds rigoureusement de
série les voitures de tout le monde et
pourtant là dans la première voiture il
y a tout simplement le président de la
république le général de gaulle est
madame de gaulle il est en vacances le
général de gaulle comme tous les
français au mois d'août mais il est
revenu là paris de colombes et avec sa
femme pour présider le conseil des
ministres qui s'est tenu à l'elysée dans
l'après midi
et maintenant il repart chez lui à la
boisserie dans sa maison cette maison
dont il a besoin
physiquement besoin oui le conseil des
ministres est bien un
il a parlé de l'avenir au conseil des
ministres le général de gaulle il a
parlé de l'allemagne il va aller en
allemagne à l'appel du chancelier
adenauer et hélas ils pensent jeter les
bases d'une grande politique
si l'allemagne la france se réconcilie
définitivement et bien de cette
association peut découler la direction à
deux de leurs hommes parce que pour le
général de gaulle l'heure a sonné de la
grande politique il y pense depuis son
retour au pouvoir en 1958 ce qu'il en a
empêché jusque là c'est la guerre
d'algérie mais c'est fini l'algérie
s'est finie pense de gaulle c'est fini
veut penser de gaulle fini alors que l'
os l'organisation de l'armée secrète
frappe
chaque jour chaque nuit partout toujours
fini fini alors qu'au conseil des
ministres monsieur foyer n'a parlé que
de l'algérie des accords de coopération
qu'il fallait signer avec la nouvelle
république algérienne des mesures pour
les rapatrier des mesures aussi à
prendre contre ce qu'on appelle les
activistes
les clandestins ceux qui lancent des
bombes alors que monsieur roger frey à
lui au même conseil des ministres une
note de quatre pages et à la page 4 il y
avait ce paragraphe toutes les
informations que nous donne toutes les
polices nous oblige à penser que le but
final aujourd'hui de la subversion
c'est l'élimination physique du chef de
l'état pendant ce qu'a dit monsieur
foyers pendant ce cas lui monsieur frais
le général de gaulle n'a rien dit ce qui
l'intéresse c'est la grande politique
c'est fini l'algérie et la voiture bien
de franchir le pont alexandra dont
personne n'a vu que sur l'avenue marie
un couple de vieilles personnes devaient
y en a beaucoup l'avenue marigny des
vieilles personnes les gens du quartier
qui l'après midi vont se promener aux
champs-elysées dans les frondaisons des
champs elysées alors les gens reviennent
chez eux à ses torts loeb peut être même
ce vieux monsieur cette vieille dame
était il assis sur un banc on ne sait
pas bien ce qu'il y assez que quand la
voiture quand les deux déesses et les
deux motards sont sortis de l'elysée
et bien ce vieux monsieur et cette
vieille dame ont suivi le cortège de
l'oeil attentivement mais c'est normal
les les chefs d'état ou qu'il règne
attire toujours les badauds il y en a
toujours avenue du faubourg saint-honoré
n'y en a toujours à la grille du coq
bien que cela ait reconnu le général de
roule et leurs gardes quoi d'étonnant
ils ne l'ont quitté du regard justement
que lorsque la voiture a franchi le pont
alexandre iii
là bas et qui s'étonneraient maintenant
que se coupent le reprenne sa marche sur
l'avenue
et qu'ils attendraient que le vieux
monsieur entre dans un café qui
s'étendrait que ce monsieur ait
téléphoné
or au même moment dans un café du petit
clamart avenue de la libération
un café qui s'appelle trianon barre à
monsieur et au comptoir derrière le
comptoir le patron et le téléphone sonne
la sur le comptoir le patron décroche
monsieur perrin à monsieur c'est vous
monsieur peyrat qui avait dit que vous
attendiez un téléphone l'autre monsieur
père a opiné bien vous l'avez votre
correspondant allez le prendre dans la
cabine des crochets monsieur perrin
alors monsieur perrin va dans la cabine
décroché au bout du fil il y a une voix
sur dix qui dit il ont franchi le pont
alexandre iii
c'est l'itinéraire numéro 2 le petit
clamart
bonne chance monsieur perrin raccroche
sort lentement de la cabine il est très
tranquille monsieur perrin c'est un
homme assez grand avec des cheveux
châtains blonds coiffés en brosse mais
surtout de toute sa personne se dégage
quelque chose qui comme une paix immense
il salue de la tête le patron et sort la
nuit tombe il est pourtant pas très tard
mais à cette heure-là à cette époque là
il n'y a pas à l'heure d'été alors la
nuit déjà commencent à tomber et
monsieur perrin gagne sa simca 1000 qui
l'attend là tout près monsieur perrin
n'existe pas il n'y a pas de monsieur
pères le véritable nom de monsieur
perrin c'est le colonel jean-marie
bastien-thiry il est au petit clamart
pour tuer le général de gaulle tout
avait commencé vous
le 1er novembre 1954 la rébellion comme
on l'avait dit en algérie alors la
guerre la guerre cruelle qui fait tâche
d'huile
la guerre qui mobilise de plus en plus
d'énergie la guerre soutenus par
l'étranger les armes qui viennent de
partout de l'union soviétique
l'argent venu des pays arabes et puis il
faut de plus en plus d'hommes pour faire
face à cette rébellion jusqu'à 500
milles les comme le contingent n'y
suffit pas il faut mobiliser des classes
et cette guerre est terriblement
impopulaire dans la métropole et les
français d'algérie le ça alors
à cette époque là il y avait des gens
qui se sentaient directement concernés
en algérie et c'était les militaires
faisaient leur travail les militaires on
leur disait vous vous battez contre les
fellaghas
mais aussi vous rallier les populations
les fellaghas y sont dans les montagnes
sont dans les lieux inaccessibles mais
l'immense majorité des musulmans en
algérie elle est disponible
alors elle a peur des faits la gamme
prouve l heure qu on ne doit pas avoir
peur des fellaghas que la france est
plus forte et qu'il faut mieux se mettre
à l'abri sous les plis du drapeau
français alors les officiers faisait
leur travail le faisait très bien
on voyait des officiers français entré
les mains nues désarmé dans des villages
où on savait qu'il y avait des rebelles
parce qu'il voulait prouver que un
français n'avait peur de rien ils
obtenaient beaucoup de succès de
ralliement mais voilà c'est que ces
officiers là c'est officiel à venait
souvent d'indochine et il avait fait
avant le même travail en indochine
on leur avait dit rallier les
populations rallier les indigènes
rallier les autochtones il l'avait fait
et beaucoup de vietnamiens étaient venus
à eux et puis un beau jour la france et
est parti laissant ces vietnamiens à me
livrer à la vindicte du viet minh et on
l'avait su que cette vindicte avait été
singulièrement cruels souvent
affreusement grenelle et ses officiers
français qui avait quitté l'indochine et
bien au fond d'eux mêmes
il portait un souvenir qui était un
remords et voilà qu'on leur faisait
faire le même travail en algérie voilà
qu'il se disait et si on partait un jour
et si ces gens qu'on amène la france à
qui on jure qu'on les protégera toujours
et si on les lâche aussi et si on les
laisse une deuxième fois
jamais disait les offices et c'est à ce
moment là que des contacts ont été pris
je pense un homme qui n'est pas un
officier mais qui représentent l'opinion
justement en algérie je pense à georges
matin georges atteint qui est un gros
propriétaire pieds-noirs l'un des plus
gros propriétaire de l'algérie 10 mille
hectares et bien georges matin dans les
années cinquante six commence à se dire
qu'il faut faire quelque chose
alors il ne rejoint pas les groupes
d'activistes
fourmies et rejoint l'armée il a des
contacts avec la est ensemble on prévoit
de faire quelques jours de faire quelque
chose en même temps se dit et le général
de gaulle
et oui il est là en réserve
il a quitté le pouvoir en 1946
volontairement et depuis il est dans son
exil de colombey les deux églises
il médite il médite sur la france cette
certaine idée de la france qu'il a
étudié toute son action
il attend
et pourtant ce n'est pas au nom du
général de gaulle que le 13 mai 58 tout
à coup se produit à alger ce qu'on peut
bien l'appeler à coup d'état à coup
d'état l'armée prend le pouvoir et
l'armée ne pense pas tout de suite à de
gaulle parce que l'armée ces salons et
salles on n'aime pas de vaud comment se
fait-il qu au balcon du forum devant une
foule immense salle ans qui vient de
faire un discours follement acclamé qui
a crié vive la france tout à coup ajoute
et personne ne s'y attend ville de vos
atouts pays la cryonie deux volets d'un
seul le mouvement est donné c'est
algérois se révèle gaulliste et la
métropole appel de gaulle je ne peux pas
vous raconter leur tour goode qui sera
appelé par le président coty
régulièrement élu par l'assemblée
nationale chargée de réformer la
constitution et qui revient au pouvoir
et qui le 4 juin en l'avion pour alger
alors quel est son opinion sur l'algérie
quelle est l'opinion de gaulle sur
l'algérie nous la connaissons très bien
parce que avant 1958 il l'a confié à
beaucoup de monde ne serait-ce qu'un
hassan ii le futur hassan ii il a confié
très précisément mary à maurice schumann
à d'autres de ses amis
il l'a d'ailleurs formulé clairement
dans une conférence de presse en 1955 il
n'a rien caché il a dit l'avenir de
l'afrique du nord et dans une
indépendance qui sera une association
avec la france
la bulle c'est ce qu'il pense en
arrivant val et le voilà aux forêts
devant une marée humaine
iman est dans cette marée humaine bien
petits pieds noirs moi je pense à celui
là en ce moment il a 18 ans et s'appelle
pierre magal du pied noir parfaitement
anonyme
il avait 18 ans il a dit plus tard on
l'a attendue s'ils se révèlent chaleur
épouvantable
les gens s'évanouissent mg on attendait
parce qu'on voulait savoir ce que les
dires de gaulle et il est là de gaulle
immense là en uniforme devant ce peuple
non moins immense et il lève ses grands
bras vers le ciel et il crie je vous ai
compris qui s'est passé ici
je vois c'est que vous avez voulu faire
je vois que la route que vous avez
souvent en algérie c'est celle de la
rénovation et de la fraternité
échaudés car qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
la france considère et dans toute
l'algérie
il y a qu une seule catégorie
d'habitants
y a que des français à part
non le goal l'apport de la
réconciliation et l'entente du pire
magath alors là jamais peut-être aucun
homme dans l'histoire n'a été autant
acclamé sur ce jour-là de gaulle pour
les algérois qui étaient là sur le forum
cela voulait dire eh oui il a compris
que nous voulons rester français alors
est ce que c'est la phrase qui échappent
vous savez vive le québec libre aussi ça
et c'est une phrase qui a échappé ça l'a
fait aussi beaucoup de bruit non elle
n'a pas échappé à de gaulle il l'écrit
dans les mémoires d'espoir j'avais tout
préparé ça n'était pas une phrase
spontanée elle était délibéré je voulais
dire je vous ai compris pour capter leur
âme et après je leur ai expliqué après
je leur ai dit que c'en était fini de la
servitude pour les uns de la domination
pour les autres que maintenant dans
cette terre d'algérie tout le monde
devait être libre
tout le monde devait avoir des droits
égaux et quand je disais des droits
égaux je voulais dire que fatalement les
musulmans d'algérie ayant les mêmes
droits que les français de souche s'en
servirait pour proclamer leur
indépendance mais il n'a quand même pas
dit ça c'est ce qu'il voulait dire
dans son esprit c'était clair ça ne l'a
pas été pour ceux qui l'écoutaient alors
il est reparti
générale le mot qui ces gens là sont
restés plein d'espoir le légionnaire
gérard buisine là-bas dans son sahara il
se souvient on l'a eu
on l'a eu il on est entière de vacances
un jour de repos et on était contents on
était content parce qu'on voyait crie
partout la france de dunkerque à
tamanrasset
l'algérie a jamais français c'était
écrit partout et buisine étaient
contents qu'il y avait des officiers
aussi qu'ils étaient heureux je pense à
l'officier qui est là-bas dans son
village au milieu et des arabes il
s'appelle alain de boer grenet de la
tocnaye 7 un lieutenant c'est un ce
justement qui ont voulu rallier les
populations l'a réussi tout à coup en
voyant ce qui se passe le 13 mai le
lieutenant de la tocnaye et émerveillés
ça va changer l'abandon c'est fini et il
fonde un comité de salut public dans son
village et il en homme
r le président il est lui-même
vice-président il envoie un télégramme à
massy ben oui tous ces gens sont heureux
et il y as au sahara un électronicien un
certain jacques prevost un ancien de
l'indochine
il a même été volontaires pour sauter
dans dien bien phu encerclé une folle
fallait le faire sauter au milieu des
viets volontaire elle en a il est
démobilisé travail comme électronicien
hausse à rhein et fier de ce qu'ont fait
aux haras et prévôt dit raja prévost a
oui quand j'ai su que de vol avait
promis et bien j'ai été rassuré j'ai été
heureux j'ai été content de gaulle
n'avait pas vraiment promis mais le
drame c'est qu'ils ont tous cru et tous
ils ont été déçus très vite très vite
parce que les déclarations faites par de
gaulle les unes après les autres avec
une sorte de régularité laissait prévoir
la négociation donc la reconnaissance du
fln donc la reconnaissance des rebelles
et alors ça voudrait dire quoi la
négociation l'indépendance pour
l'algérie et oui voilà que de gaulle
tout à coup dans un discours annoncé que
l'algérie déciderait de son sort et
qu'il fallait penser que ce sort serait
l'indépendance
l'association avec la france bien sûr
mais l'indépendance alors bien sûr de
gaulle annonce qu'il fera en sorte que
les droits des français d'algérie seront
garantis mais ils n'y croient plus ces
français d'algérie et alors et alors les
groupes d'action se multiplient de
nouveau et ce sera ce qu'on appelle la
semaine des barricades
tentative pour refaire un 13 mais on ne
refait jamais la même chose l'histoire
le démontre
je les ai cela échoue et voilà que le
plus en plus on s'achemine vers la
négociation et de gaulle annonce qu'elle
aura lieu cette négociation est pris au
nom de la femme la décision que voici
les algériens disent fuseront et
librement de leur destin
c'est moi qui porte le destin du pays
les soldats préfets doivent donc mme
aubry et le gouvernement provisoire de
la république algérienne le gpr à
annonce qu'il est prêt à cette
négociation alors c'est fini les
généraux décide que ce ne sera pas fini
et au début 2009 161 et bien tout à coup
ils prennent le pouvoir à alger
c'est ce qu'on appelle le putsch des
généraux ils sont quatre général salan
le général joue le général challe le
général zeller 4 qu'est ce qu'il veut le
saf qui le même ils veulent prendre le
contrôle de l'algérie et ayant pris le
contrôle de l'algérie peut être réussir
dans une seconde étape le contrôle de la
france où il racontait des amis
la france réprouve leurs gestes leurs
actes de gaulle paraît à la télévision
le de gaulle des grands jours en
uniforme
il parle à la caméra pour parler à la
france
hélas hélas hélas hélas france l'entente
et les soldats d'afrique du nord
l'entente au noir de la fin j'ordonne
que tout les moyens
jeudi tous les moyens soit employé pour
barrer la route à ces hommes là en
attendant de les réduire
j'ai interdit à tout français est
d'abord à tout soldat d'exécuter en cas
de l'ordre françaises français voyez où
risque d'aller là fort par rapport à ce
qu'elle était en train de re de vie
françaises français
elio noir tout s'effondre aux quelques
heures alors le général challe est le
général dallaire se rendent général
jouer le général salan rentrer dans la
clandestinité
mais voilà l'échec du putsch des
généraux
ce fameux quarteron de généraux comme a
dit de gaulle et bien l'échec du putsch
comporte une conséquence de taille c'est
que le 16 mai 1960 et se forme dans une
maison d'un quartier populaire d'alger
ce qu'on appellera low as organisation
de l'armée secrète il y à là dans cette
maison que par là le général gardie il
ya là le colonel godard il y à là le
capitaine sergent il y à l'ats le
lieutenant degueldre susini devrait y
être l'ancien président des étudiants
d'alger il s'est perdu il n'a pas trouvé
la maison
il y est moralement comme il est
moralement le colonel argoud argoud qui
a dû partir pour la métropole et jour et
salan qui n'y sont pas ont fait
connaître leur accord qu'est ce que
veulent os vient il ya un mot cette
époque là qu'on n'utilise pas encore
c'est déstabiliser mais c'est un mot qui
veut tout dire car c'est bien le rôle de
l'aurès le res me semer le désordre en
algérie d'abord dans la métropole
ensuite un désordre absolu faire que les
français dans ce désordre finissent par
l'imputé à de gaulle l'europe proche à
de gaulle pour que finalement de gaulle
soit littéralement jetés or le pouvoir
ils ne veulent plus de gaulle ils ne
veulent plus des gaullistes
alors ces [ __ ] s frapper partout
affolé les français les inquiète et les
angoisses et créer les conditions d'une
prise de pouvoir par d'autres qui
apparaîtront comme un recours
voilà ce que veut le reste c'est
extraordinairement ambitieux personne
dans l'histoire n'a jamais tenté une
chose pareille il le temps d' euros
frappe
en algérie on réussit parce que le res
elle est chez elle en algérie elle est
appuyé par tous soutenus par tous en
métropole non en métropole où s est
extrêmement impopulaire parce que ce
plastique qui éclatent partout et puis
aux six morts car elle qui l'aurait ce
lance une bombe chez monsieur malraux et
puis c'est une petite fille défigurée
le visage de cette petite fille apparaît
par tous les français
c'est difficile d'agir en métropole pour
la belgique quand même mais de gaulle
impavide poursuit sa voie et en mars on
est à evian le gouvernement français
d'une part le gouvernement provisoire de
la république algérienne de l'autre et
le 18 mars on signe les accords d'evian
et le 19 mars à midi en proclament en
algérie le cessez le feu
cette en ces temps de guerre c'est fini
la guerre d'algérie fini fini pour les
français d'algérie n'est pas question
que ce soit fini quoi ça y est c'est
fini on nous vend on nous braves
non nous ne voulons pas nous n'acceptons
pas et l'ol ne l'acceptent pas on a
pourtant arrêté jour le premier il a été
transféré en métropole jugé condamné à
mort il sera heureusement gracié et
voilà qu'on arrête également salants
conduit en métropole jugé il n'est pas
condamné à mort de gaulle furieux crée
alors une cour militaire de justice que
l'on pourra sans doute tenir mieux en
main alors c'est l'époque de
l'apocalypse pendant ces mois que ces
semaines qui suivent
personne ne sait plus où on en est les
gens meurent il y a quelques fois 250
m'en rende
jour les il y à des drames affreux comme
la rue 10 lyon où on voit des soldats
français tirait sur des foules française
et l'on voit également des morts
innocents qui meurent du fait de l'aurès
qu'est ce que cherche l'ol s'est fait
c'est signé ce que veulent os est prouvé
que les accords d'evian sont
inapplicables et qu'on ne pourra pas les
expliquer alors qu'on suscite partout le
désordre le plus affreux la crainte la
terreur et oui c'est le régime de la
terreur loes créer l'intérêt je me
souviens de doran tout à la fin que ces
deux mois des fumées du port il y avait
un arabe tué à chaque carrefour les
trottoirs et incluant deux sens je me
souviens 2 et encore on être sa part a
dit à côté d'alger je me souviens de de
l'incendié de la bibliothèque de faculté
à alger c'était c'était vraiment la
dévastation après nous les cas que rien
après une campagne plus rien cette table
peut-être à ces femmes est insupportable
en tout cas pas du tout pas du tout
fallu tout dans là dedans la vérité du
pays c'est à dire que il voulait bien
ils voulaient bien il voulait bien être
et gonflé mais
avec un triomphe c'était le triomphe des
maîtres des des français qui lui restent
et les battre des anciens coloniaux qui
restaient les maîtres
c'est de ça que nous ne pouvons pas
supporter la francité delà d'une façon
plus ou moins injuste il fallait que
justice soit rendue aux angels et il y
avait tout de même une partie de la
france qui luttait pour sa contre l'oas
mai c'est se battre pour rien c'est le
combat inutile ce combat qui n'est pas
soutenue par les français la métropole
alors le 19 juillet 1962
l'orece en quelque sorte reconnaît sa
défaite puisque on abandonne le cycle de
l'aurès qu'il n'y a plus de rs
mais il ya autre chose il y a le cnr
qu'est ce que c'est que le sénat le
conseil national de la résistance et ses
salles ans du fond de sa prison qui a
désigné son successeur le président du
cnr georges bidault quoi georges bidault
et oui georges bidault l'ancien
président du premier conseil national de
la résistance du premier ses nerfs
pendant la guerre pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale pendant l'occupation
l'organisme qui a regroupé tous les
mouvements de résistance et et bideau
qui le présidait le voilà de nouveau
étrangement paradoxalement de nouveau
président d'un autre ses nerfs alors les
gens du cnr où sont ils pas à paris pas
en france bien sûr georges bidault
l'ancien ministre du général de gaulle
ancien président du conseil georges
bidault est à l'étranger
jacques soustelle le gaulliste
inconditionnel l'un des auteurs du 13
mai 58 et bien jacques soustelle est
devenu le premier des anti gaulliste il
est également au delà de nos frontières
il yal colonel argoud ils se réunissent
quand ils le peuvent ils animent ce
qu'ils appellent la résistance est alors
justement que l'année 62 s'avance que
l'été approche
la résistance du cnr n'a plus qu'un but
la vengeance se libérer de la gaule se
venger de gaulle
le bradeurs le traître et comment s'en
venger en lecture ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'on a pensé a tué de
gaulle
depuis qu'il est là et bien avant on a
déjà voulu le tuer fier des mre
christian plumes ont dénombré 31
attentat contre le général de gaulle
attentats ou tentatives d'attentât la
dernière elle a eu lieu le 8 septembre
1961 à pont-sur-seine on l'avait préparé
une machine infernale une bombe chargée
d'explosifs avec du napalm qui devait
éclater sur le passage de la voiture du
général servant de paris à
colombey-les-deux-églises mais voilà
c'est que les plastiques n'ont pas bien
été associés la bombe n'a pas éclaté
seul napalm s'est répandue et a brûlé la
voiture s'est trouvé devant un rideau de
flammes et le chauffeur du général le
maréchal des logis maroua eu la présence
d'esprit de fond c'est à travers ce
rideau de flammes c'est le dernier
attentat contre le goal mais maintenant
62 on cherche à aller plus loin et un
homme a été choisi pour aller plus loin
cet homme c'est le colonel jean-marie
bastien-thiry voyez vous dans cette
affaire nous allons retrouver des hommes
que nous avons déjà vu je pense par
exemple à georges vatin cette espèce de
force de la nature ce bulldozer de
l'insurrection à bien en jambes at on
trouve logique qu'ils soient dans
l'aurès on trouve logique qui se lancent
dans des affaires de ce genre
voyez vous même le lieutenant de la
tocnaye oui c'est indécent dans le chou
ans et il sort d'une famille on s'est
rebellé depuis des siècles c'est normal
mais pourquoi bastien thiry
j'ai retiré la pression des très longues
conversations que j'ai eues avec bastien
thiry qu'il a voulu s'offrir en
holocauste se répète le terme parce que
c'est le sentiment que j'éprouve il a
voulu en somme accomplir un geste
exemplaire
voilà un garçon qui à 35 ans était
colonel de l'armée française qui était
polytechnicien c'est un très brillant
sujet qui avait fait l'école supérieure
de l'aéronautique qui était l'inventeur
de fusées r
air-sol qu'ils étaient capables
d'expérimenter lui même car il était
pilote d'essai il était parti d'ans
sahara pour faire précisément ces essais
de fusées et il avait découvert
l'afrique du nord qu'il ne connaissait
pas dans les années 60 il a été
littéralement frappé de ce que
représentait en capital humain au
capital sentimentale et en capital
économique l'algérie
il a considéré qu'il était impossible
d'abandonner les français d'algérie
d'abandonner les musulmans d'algérie
d'abandonner les pétroles saharien qui
nous avait coûté tellement d'efforts
tellement de travail tellement de peine
à découvrir et à mettre en exploitation
et il s'est fait le raisonnement suivant
je suis à peu près sûr de ce que je dis
il s'est fait le raisonnement suivant il
s'est dit moi qui suis officier qui est
ce un galon sur les manches ne jamais
verser mon sens et j'ai fait don de ma
personne à la france le jour où j'ai
signé un contrat d'engagement dans
l'armée
par conséquent il faut que je fasse
quelque chose pour sauver l'algérie pour
garder ces trois départements français
de gaulle est apparu à ses yeux comme
l'unique responsable de la théorie de
l'abandon il appartenait à une famille
de gaulliste convaincu il était lui-même
en adoration devant l'homme du 18 juin
et tout d'un coup cet homme est apparu à
lui comme l'unique responsable de
l'abandon de ce que représentait
l'algérie française
alors il a décidé de s'emparer de sa
personne peut être de le tuer jean était
un père très doux il aimait la vie
paisible puis vinrent les événements
d'algérie et là il changera profondément
parce qu'il souffrait il souffrait de
tout ce qu'il voyait tout ce qu il
entendait il n'était plus un homme
vivant sa simple vie quotidienne il
était là bas avec
souffrant leurs souffrances et il se
disait ce n'est pas possible que moi je
puisse être à l'abri
il faut faire quelque chose et c'est
pourquoi il a tenté quand plus rien ne
pouvait être tenté
il a tenté l'impossible d'arrêter le
bras qui faisait tant de mal
et pourtant bastien thiry longtemps est
resté non pas indifférent m'éloigner
il n'a pas approuvé l'oaci la coladera
même sévèrement il condamnera ses excès
inutile et il dira que l'ouest est morte
de ses erreurs et ses excès il
n'approuve pas non plus les premiers
attentats contre de gaulle quand il en
parle du pas sérieux car c'est un homme
sérieux bastien thiry très serré l'homme
qui l'a contacté et rallier semblait
très jean bichon un haut responsable de
l'oms dont on a peu parlé et jean-marie
bastien-thiry se trouvait déjà à
l'origine de la sphère de pont-sur-seine
et oui avec un exécutant un personnage
étrange un français tunisie qui lui
aussi a tout perdu en quittant la
tunisie armand belvisi dur et force de
la nature
on m'a demandé si je voulais participer
à une grosse opération
j'ai dit oui et on m'a dit vous avez
rendez vous aux fontaines de la porte
saint cloud à 21h avec un monsieur et
grands qui porte un imperméable
militaire et vous aurez le contact avec
lui permettrait à sa disposition et vous
avez l'air et je suis allé à la porte
saint cloud choses allaient rencontrer
le colonel bastien thiry je savais pas
qu'il s'appelait qu'il était le cône
elle va s'étirer à l'époque mais les
gens qui me go qui me guide et m'ont
demandé de me mettre à sa disposition
je me suis donc mis à sa disposition
donc quand je les ai vus j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir affaire à un
militaire dans sa tenue il était d'une
très grand blond
il parlait posément il m'a vraiment
impressionné il avait un regard qui
était frappant
il m'a demandé si je voulais participer
à une grosse opération
j'ai dit oui et c'est là qu'il m'a
donnés rendez-vous à 120 km de paris
pour rencontrer les autres membres du
commando qui ont participé au premier
attentat celui de pont sur sable et les
contacts ont dû être étrange entre cet
homme froid
le mathématicien bastia thiriez
l'effervescent belvisi et puis les
chèque de pont-sur-seine a atteint
semble-t-il profondément bastien thiry
ce n'est qu'en février 62 que jean
bichon vient le voir de nouveau et lui
dit seriez vous disposé à monter une
nouvelle opération contre le guide
oui le guide c'est le nom je dis ça pour
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
le guide c'est le nom que l'on donnait
que l'opposition donné à l'époque cas de
gaulle par dérision la plus logique
alors rem en février 62 massa terry
donne son accord à une nouvelle
opération et jean michon lui dit je vais
vous présenter quelqu'un d'intéressant
ce quelqu'un s'appelle alain de la
tocnaye nous l'avons déjà rencontré je
ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez de cet
officier qui la bat v créer un comité de
salut public dans son village et bien
cet officier il avait participé au
putsch s'était rallié au pot du des
généraux et puis après le putsch il
était entré dans la nature s'étaient
rapprochés lors s et puis on l'avait
arrêté jeté en prison à la santé à paris
et puis s'était évadé d'ailleurs dans
des conditions parfaitement
rocambolesque et il venait de sortir et
il avait fait savoir parce qu'il y avait
des filières dans l'aurès et avec ça il
avait fait savoir qu'il était disponible
pour une affaire sérieuse un coup
sérieux alors savez ce que ça voulait
dire tous les coups sérieux qu'on
voulait entreprendre cette époque
avaient la même raison d'être tué le
groupe alors un beau jour ch dans la
planque de la tocnaye
bichon amène bastia et la tocnaye frappé
par leur parce que tous ceux qui verront
bastien thiry sont frappés 1,7
c'est un homme peur et à son regard et
son maintien et surtout cette certitude
tube cette pureté aussi alors les hommes
sympathisent et d'emblée bastien thiry
expose son plan de pipe on sur scène on
a convaincu le général de gaulle qui
refuse toute opération de sécurité du
haut de sa grandeur il n'en veut parer
c'est comme ça mais quand même depuis
pont-sur-seine et les services générale
ne prenait plus la voiture est là quand
même il axe alors maintenant quand il va
à colombey-les-deux-églises il va en
voiture de l'elysée à villacoublay
là il prend un avion qui le dépose à
saint dizier et là une voiture le
conduit de saint dizier à colombey les
deux églises et quand il rentre c'est le
contraire naturellement alors dit
bastien thiry voilà on ne peut plus le
frapper contre saint dizier colombes et
autres villacoublay l'elysée j'ai choisi
par et pourquoi ni l'adopter c'est aussi
bien à banon et bastien thiry là bas
comme il faut que nous soyons trois
voitures nous soyons plusieurs on our
repérera plus facilement dans paris nous
passeront inaperçus lors nous frappons
la page elle vous hammam suivre l
attaque n'est naturellement est d'accord
alors on se donne rendez-vous un peu
plus tard dans les jardins du trocadéro
et c'est là que bastien thiry et bichon
présenteront à la tocnaye armand belvisi
ils voulaient me présenter le chef
militaire de l'odieux de l'attentât du
petit clamart et le collen basse intérim
avait demandé si je voulais participé à
l'attentât et j'ai dit oui
il m'a demandé si je pouvais lui fournit
désormais du matériel j'ai dit oui
alors lequel elle m'a dit je vais vous
présenter le togolais de la tocnaye qui
est un qui sera le patron de l'opération
et ça s'est passé ici ça c'est
patientons fédéraux et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ensuite alors le met ensuite
j'ai présenté le temps que le colonel
bassetti répartie je suis resté avec le
brûler de la tocnaye qu'on appelait la
tête et je suis allé deux sur les ponts
qui partent depuis le pont de la tour
eiffel en allant vers l'assemblée
nationale pour présenter à chaque conte
un des membres du commando
à chaque fois il y avait un membre du
commando qui étaient là et qu'ils
attendaient que je présente le tambour
relais de la tocnaye vous étiez en
voiture en était en voiture le temps mon
rôle est de le protéger avec moi on a
fait les ponts chaque pont pour
présenter chaque membre du commando j
comment j'ai présenté en premier vatin
georges bernier les trois ans gr varga
maarten et ghilas harry
[Musique]
pas les nommer dans l'ordre de leur
intrusion dans la sphère mais je peux
citer jacques prévost et oui jacques
prévost nous l'avons déjà trouvé au
sahara l'électronicien l'homme qui a
sauté à diên biên phu et bat le voilà et
puis voilà gérard buisine gérard buisine
vous vous souvenez le légionnaire il
avait entendu devons le dire le patron
les français à jamais et nulle arables
et puis voilà même le petit pied noir
pierre mas gad
ils étaient mobilisés il faisait son
service et puis l'a déserté au milieu
des événements il a décidé de se lancer
dans l'action clandestine et il est là
aussi
mais tous ces hommes et vous même allez
pas vous étiez tous dans la même idée
qu'il fallait tuer devons absolument
nous étions convaincus que la la
suppression du chef de l'état nous
permettait de garder l'algérie en ce qui
me concerne je suis pieds noirs
d'origine
j'estime que mon devoir était de d'aller
aider l'algérie et on m'a demandé de le
faire je les fais volontairement et sans
aucune arrière pensée
je pensais que pour nous la suppression
du chef de l'état nous aurait permis de
garder l'algérie à la france
et puis viendront encore louis condé
d'une grande famille que les autres
endroits un peu mondain mais où cette
personne sera vite que c'est un homme un
de ces hommes qui se font tuer plutôt
que de céder la place qu'on leur a
confiées il y aura encore constantin n'y
aura encore bertin il y aura encore du
casse
il n'y en aura d'autres ces gens là se
réunissent régulièrement il ya un
briefing de bastien thiry on étudiait
les cartes on sait que il ya deux
itinéraires pour aller l'elysée à
villacoublay l'un par le petit clamart l
autre par meudon etc alternativement de
gaulle empreinte relais deux itinéraires
on sait aussi bastien thiry le raconte à
ses hommes qu'il a installé des
guetteurs au bon endroit notamment la
sortie de l'elysée que ces guetteurs
sont à même de lui signaler qu'elle sera
l'itinéraire que de gaulle prendra parce
que c'est très facile c'est au pont
3 que ça se dessine si on va d'un côté
et bien on va me les ont si on va de
l'autre on va au petit clamart
alors les guetteurs téléphone il n'y a
mieux c'est que bastien thiry un
informateur à l'intérieur même de
l'elysée parce que ce n'est pas un
guetteur qui est sur le trottoir qui
peut dire trois jours à l'avance le
général reviendra de colombes et à telle
date
et pourtant bastien thiry le c'est donc
l'homme qui peut prévoir ça à l'avancé
qu'ils appellent bastia terry est un
proche de nouveau cet homme là n'a
jamais été décelée jamais dévoilées il
est probablement vivent aujourd'hui
peut-être me regarde t-il en ce moment
on ne sait pas qui vous êtes monsieur
assurez-vous et c'est le mois doublé dit
les vacances alors de vous et là bas
à la boisserie nommé lieu de césar face
à cet immense plaine vont laquelle il a
rêvé de 1946 1958 devant laquelle si
souvent il a pensé à cette certaine idée
de la france de se forger depuis
l'enfance avec un mélange de regret et
d'amour l'amertume et d'espoir alors oui
il est à colombes et mais il revient
pour le conseil et le vin le vin tout
justement
l'informateur de bastien thiry lui fait
savoir que le goal sera pour le 22 à
paris 22 après midi pour présider
justement un conseil des ministres alors
sera-t-il là le 21 ça lui arrive de
revenir la veille quand il ya tout de
même des affaires en cours ou bien
arrivera-t-il le matin on ne sait pas
alors le 21 tout le monde est sur le
pied de guerre on attend les voitures
sont prêtes
les armes sont prêtes les hommes sont
prêts on l'attend toute la journée rien
alors rendez-vous 6h30
le lendemain matin chez l'un des
conjurés ducasse rue de vaugirard un
petit déjeuner copieux parce qu'il faut
se donner du coeur revente
on est là écoute téléphone il est parti
de colombes et le groupe et il arrive
par l'itinéraire qui passe par le petit
clamart
alors cette fois on va le saisir sur la
venue du maire
et l'avenue du maine les trois voitures
font jusque là stop à l'angle de la rue
raymond losserand pour attendre le
cortège présidentiel qui vient de passer
eh ben ils ont perdu quelques minutes
magan
le chauffeur qui le petit pied noir qui
a remplacé constantin qui était malade
s'est trompé dans une rue et puis voilà
trop tard alors maintenant il ya plus
qu'a attendre leur tour cas les plus
fortes raisons de penser qu'il reviendra
le soin et revient toujours le soir il
n'aime pas rester à paris dans ces cas
là alors toute la journée on va attendre
dit l'homme qu'attend à meudon dans
l'appartement de monique bertin la soeur
de bertin l'un des conjurés alors ils
sont là il tue le temps comme ils
peuvent y en a toujours brillé y en a
qui lisent mais y en a toujours un qui
est à la fenêtre
le rideau est baissé mais il soulève le
coin d'un rideau pour regarder l'heure
et le soir un peu après 19 heures 45
tout à coup alors que la nuit tombe il
voit arrêté en bas une simca 1000 1
hommes en descendent qui agite un
journal et le guetteur se retourne vers
les autres ça y est alors immédiatement
tout le monde debout tout le monde dans
l'escalier on court et c'est la tocnaye
et prévôt qui sont les premiers à la
simca 1000 les bassins terry est là dans
la simca 1000 bastia et eric qui vient
d'avoir le goût de téléphone sous le nom
de monsieur perrin co j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure au trianon bar du petit clamart
et il dit avenue de la libération
petit clamart bonne chance lp le 22 août
1962 19h40 général est monté dans la
voiture à l'arrière gauche madame de
gaulle à l'avant à l'arrière droite et
le général de boissieu a pris place à
l'avant de droite à côté du chauffeur
lorsque les portières ont été fermées
les glaces montée m'a donné ordre
d'aller à villacoublay direction
châtillon par le petit clamart et il a
dit plus tard je suis sûr que personne
n'a pu entendre
l'itinéraire que j'avais fixé c'est vrai
personne mais le colonel le monsieur ne
pouvait pas savoir qu'il y avait sur le
trottoir de l'avenue marigny un couple
singulièrement intéressé justement par
la direction calais prendre la voiture
présidentielle
alors bien sûr derrière cette première
voiture à l'arrière il ya
général de gaulle à gauche madame de
gaulle à droite et puis dans la seconde
voiture conduite par le brigadier
kaeslin il y a trois ans un médecin
le médecin de gosse et puis deux
commissaires chargés de la sécurité le
commissaire puissant le commissaire jude
et puis derrière deux matins de gardiens
de la paix motocyclistes alors rond la
proche on a franchi la porte de
châtillon
on approche du petit clamart et le
maréchal des logis ma roue s'est dit
qu'on n'a plus que quatre kilomètres
pour arriver à villacoublay dans
l'avenue de la libération
c'est le nom de l'avenue au petit
clamart
les trois voitures des conjurés ont pris
place
et puis bastien thiry lui seul n'est pas
en voiture il s'est installé sur un
trottoir le trottoir de droite quand on
vienne paris il y a là un château d'eau
et il est là debout avec un journal à la
main ce journal doit lui servir à faire
un signal avertir les autres que les
voitures à poche
et puis encore plus loin à peu près 250
mètres de l'endroit où se trouve bastien
thiry sur la droite il y a les staffs et
joe et imaginer ses hommes dans cet état
fait avec cette ouverture simplement qui
a été préparé
et il regarde et il regarde comme on dit
dans michel strogoff de tous leurs yeux
il regarde il regarde là bas là bas où
se trouve
bastien thiry à 250 mètres devant avec
un journal et les hommes qui regardent
la savent que quand bastien thiry qui
est en quelque sorte en avant postes sur
l'avenue de la libération vers paris eh
bien ils savent que temps bastien thiry
verra arriver le cortège du général de
gaulle il lèvera couru alors il atteint
mais le drame c'est qu'il ne voit rien
la nuit est tombée et bastia tiric ton
livre verra arriver le cortège aura
venue de son journal ici dans cette
voiture
bernier les hongrois guise in person le
verra le geste de bastien thiry
alors donc imaginons ces gens dans la
nuit qui attend et l'un d'eux le
hongrois varga mais il a un besoin
naturel
tout le monde est loin d'avoir un besoin
naturel il descend et il descend
simplement avec son revolver ne descend
pas avec son fusil mitrailleur on ne
prend pas de fusil mitrailleur dans ces
cas là en général et au moment où il est
dehors il vient juste de finir tout à
coup dans la nuit
le cortège qui la perçoit il hurle et
voilà les voilà et c'est saric qui vont
dit le premier en dehors de la voiture
cependant que lui varg avec son revolver
tirs sur la voiture sari lui avec son
fusil mitrailleur à rosenau
la voiture et c'est ce geste de sarry
leucan au dessus des mitrailleurs que le
chauffeur m'a rovera nous voulions à peu
près entre 90 et 100 kilomètres heures
lorsq arriver à 200 mètres de prix après
le carrefour de meudon il y avait une
estafette arrêté sur le bas côté droit
de la route et l'âme qui était sur le
trottoir
arrivé à veut pas s'en mettre cette
voiture un coup de feu a claqué et j'ai
aperçu le canot de larmes
à ce moment là j'ai appuyé sur
l'accélérateur à fond ce qui nous a
permis de nous dégager ils ont continué
à tirer et le général de boissieu a
demandé au général de gaulle et madame
de se baisser
vous direz pas s'ils l'ont fait parce
que je vais te sens tu as regardé et
j'ai senti mes mots un coup dans l'eau
va dans la direction et je présume que
c'était un moment la camaro
j'avais tiré dans la roue avant droite
je suis ici rue du bois
exactement à l'endroit où se trouvait
l'idée 19 une idée 19 comme celle ci que
conduisait la tocnaye au volant vatin à
côté de lui
prévost à l'arrière de la voiture alors
quel était le rôle de l'idée 19 au
moment même où le signal serait donné
par la fusillade qu'ils entendraient de
l'estafette foncé en avant traverser
l'avenue s'immobiliser au milieu de
l'avenue de manière à stopper le cortège
présidentiel au cas où la fusillade le
leur et pasteur mais au moment où la
fusillade éclat la tocnaye et bien à son
volant prévost et bien à l'arrière mais
vatin n'est pas dans la boîte va étaler
et sas disons que c'est une très
curieuse idée 20 ans est allé à pied
voir si le cortège arrive de sorte qu'il
a perdu lui aussi un moment précieux
avant de revenir d'ouvrir la portière de
s'asseoir et ce n'est qu'à ce moment là
que la tocnaye a démarré en trombe et
quand il a voulu barrer la rue c'était
trop tard le cortège présidentiel veut
les passes arrivé à hauteur de la rue du
bois une voiture qui débouche c'était
une idée bleus à toit blanc comme une
passion devant elle elle a tiré
c'est ce qui a crevé de celle à royan
gauche et puis elle s'est intercalé
entre la voiture de sécurité puis nous
et elle a quand il lui a tiré par
l'arrière
et la fusillade a duré jusqu'au
rond-point du petit-clamart ce moment là
cette voiture là nous a quittés
et nous nous avons continué sur
villacoublay ça tirait de partout et
cette même voiture avril s'est imposée
entre ma voiture et la voiture du
général de gaulle vous lavant bien
entendu notre chauffeur qui s'appelle
cas cela qui est un homme d'un courage
inouï et je dois le dire c'était notre
sauveur c'est qu'aulas la voiture du
général où nous avons donc suivi tout le
temps pis encore d'autres tirs sur notre
droite je n'ai pas pu tirer parce que
quand même de quoi tire pas j'étais
venue d'une mitraillette
j'avais un chargeur et cela ne pouvait
servir que si le général est arrêtée si
la voiture général était bloquée devait
lanka ce moment là bien entendu sortir
au prix de ma vie écrit alors que j'ai
des graves et ça et je dois dire que la
vitesse nous a beaucoup sauvé arrivé au
rond point du petit clamart
la voiture qui nous tiraient dessus nous
a quittés elle a tourné vers la droite
et nous avons continué sur villa couple
est alors arrivée à villacoublay nous
avons arrêté la voiture je suis descendu
comme d'habitude ou à la portière au
général il est descendu à brosser son
veston examen parce qu'il avait des
éclats de verre et la quitter en
remerciant comme il a coutume de le
faire on arrêtait de deux voitures
j'ai vu que la voiture du général d'un
côté elle a été le carreau été
complètement foutu en l'air je peux dire
bon petit morceau les deux pneus étaient
bloqués ce qui veut dire des kits sa
voiture et de le rester encore cinq
cents mètres à faire donc là pris notre
voiture pour y aller je vais quand même
s'il est une chose qui me semble belle à
dire c'est de courage de madame de
vannes ne parlons pas du général tout le
monde le sait c'est des gens qui
s'encouragent parle de tout et peut
avoir peur de rien je dois d'abord par
sa croyance il croit en dieu comme nous
tous d'ailleurs pas sans moi aussi mais
on ne peut pas dire qu'on avait eu peur
parce que tout ça se passe très vite là
qu'après la voiture et je vous dis ça
m'a surprise c'est qu'elle vit une
petite mallette d'iam la voiture du
général madame de gaulle le père de tous
à ce moment là c'est dire écoutez
excusez moi j'ai un camp dit mallett et
est allé la chercher
et puis la voiture la présente ma
voiture et là continuer et nous nous
avons donc pris à pied pendant 500
mètres allait regagner l'avion mais
peut-être que du sud a dit une chose
c'est que nous avons eu 2 1
un motard que les temps levé sans casque
roman et d'enlever évite une balle qui
avait traversé le casque et puis la
balle avait tourné autour du casque mais
se rendre compte du trou il pensait que
peut être on avait quelque chose c'est
que nous avons vis ce geste comme ça
démarre étendue et puis je crois que
tout le corps était étendu les temps d
voilà ce que je peux vous dire un peu
très succinctement mais peut-être aussi
dois le dire que le général de gaulle a
fait une réflexion qui est celle ci
i pour cette fois c'était en jean mais
terreau si mal et moi je peux vous dire
une chose et n'ont pas tiré si mal vous
avez la chance et dieu était avec ses
pierres magath qui sera arrêté lé
premier pas
contrôle de routine et les déserteurs
vos papiers il est sur la liste on
l'arrête on interroge route une petite
déserteurs sang importante et c'est lui
qui dit j'étais au petit clamart
pourquoi c'est pas épouvanter ou tout à
coup pour se donner l'important c'est ce
qu'on sait danser galles et c'est lui
qui donnera tous les noms
alors on les arrêtera mais après les
autres c'est plus très difficile lors
certains échapperont comme matin comme
condé comme d'autres enfin disons que
bastien thiry la tocnaye prévost
et à l'autre seront dans le box des
accusés alors le procès va s'ouvrir
[Musique]
au fort neuf de vincennes dans la salle
longue et triste sans fenêtre du
tribunal militaire du nouveau tribunal
militaire
et à part les incidents de procédure
abandons dont on parlera beaucoup
équivaudront à maîtrise horny trois
années de suspension et bien ce qui va
dominer les débats
incontestablement c'est la personnalité
de jean marie bastien il est là
au milieu de ses co accusés ne se défend
pas du tout il explique il explique
pourquoi il a voulu tuer de gaulle et
aujourd'hui quand on relit ou qu'on
entend ces propos est bien au courant
ce n'est pas pour les juges qu'il parle
c'est pour l'histoire
alors je vous donne la parole colonel
bastien thiry pouvoir y met à rêver
le terme en dollar est en grève il
fallait leur donner des gages de volonté
pour conserver et à venir ce pouvoir
auquel on venait par deux et dont on se
croyait avoir à régler
ils ont sans ajustement frustré mais là
un point essentiel et qui portèrent
enlève tout seul ni à réduire en vrai
dans terme ans il n'était pas vaine
libéral de l'actuel chef de l'état
mon rêve ils étaient aidés
et non pouvoir envers et contre tout en
utilisant les moyens
elle est maintenant et plus et maman les
prix vont d'allah les mentons alors le
jugement des peines de détention à
perpétuité à temps et puis pour bastien
thiry pour la tocnaye pour prévost la
mort la tocnaye prévost seront graciés
et un jour de mars 1963 4h30 du matin la
porte de la cellule à la prison de
fresnes où dort jean-marie bastien-thiry
est ouverte et rentrer le cortège
d'hommes noirs traditionnels dans ces
cas là le procureur général le directeur
de la prison les avocats le médecin
d'autres maître richard dupuis qui a
plaidé pour bastien thiry avec m tixier
vignancour s'approche bastien thiry
s'éveille se dresse sa première question
et mes amis
gracié mon colonel dit richard de paix
j'en suis heureux heureux pour eux ils
se lèvent s'habille dans un profond
silence on a aménagé dans la pièce
voisine une chapelle de fortune bastien
thiry est un grand croyant il va écouter
la messe l'a servi et il va communier
d'une demi hostile parce que l'autre
moitié de l'eau style l'aumônier la
conservera pour madame bastien thiry
laquelle communiera quelques heures plus
tard
ite missa est c'est fini et là dans le
couloir tout à coup les avocats suscite
un nouvel incident de procédure il
demande à nouveau sursis d'exécution
on discute longuement mais bastien thiry
est loin très loin loin le tout on
l'entend murmurer mais tout cela est il
bien utile alors le procureur répond
rejette les nouvelles conclusions c'est
fini on part le long cortège dans les
couloirs de la prison la porte ouverte
l'air froid du matin il pleut le fourgon
cellulaire
le fort d'ivry il est 6 heures 38 quand
bastien thiry découvre le peloton
d'exécution ces soldats français qui
doivent tirer sur un officier français
et ont la tâche aux poteaux et ses mains
attachées tiennent un chapelet
6h40 la salve m tixier vignancour qui se
penchera sur le corps étendus là dans
l'herbe dira il avait l'air d'un
adolescent très pur un peu plus tard le
général de gaulle parlera de bastien
thiry ya l'un de ses familiers compagnon
de la libération
il dira il faut aux français des martyrs
mais il faut qu'il les choisit ce bien
moi je leur ai donné bastien thiry
[Musique]
s'arrêtera l'instant il ajoutera
quand j'aurai disparu qu'il soit donc
leur marque et le mérite
[Musique]
un martyr oui nous savons que de gaulle
n'a pas refusé son estime à bastien
thiry un martyr peut-être mais si nous
nous posons cette question et si bastien
thiry avait tué de gaulle
si bastien thiry avait réussi à tuer de
gaulle
alors quel serait le jugement de
l'histoire l'indépendance de l'algérie
était non seulement une fatalité mais
une nécessité historique
le drame c'est qu'elle s'est accompli
dans le sang le drame c'est qu'un
million de français ont été chassés de
leur terre natale et à l'époque à
l'époque nous en métropole nous ne les
avions pas ces français là nous les
rendons responsable des excès doha et si
aujourd'hui nous avons pour eux de
l'affection à cause du courage qu'ils
ont manifesté pour se réinsérer dans la
communauté nationale de gaulle en
voulant l'indépendance de l'algérie de
gaulle en réussissant l'immense
entreprise de décolonisation de gaulle à
manifester une fois de plus qu'il était
un profond politique
alors si bastien thiry avait réussi à
tuer de gaulle alors il ya ceux qui ont
été au petit clamart à l'époque comme
beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai détesté ces
âmes l'art je les aie aie
aujourd'hui je ne vais pas dire que je
les excuses mais vingt années ont passé
d'ailleurs on n'a jamais le droit
l'excusé quelqu'un qui veut tuer le chef
de l'état qui veut d'ailleurs tuer
n'importe lequel de ses adversaires
politiques s'est jamais une solution
mais si on ne les excuse pas on peut
arriver à les comprendre et je dirais
que c'est mon cas
ce qui tend à prouver que une fois de
plus injuste avait raison quand il
disait à la convention nationale on ne
règne pas innocemment
[Musique]